okay Lindy Lindy butts butters
yes yes you are originally from South
Africa but you live in Singapore yes
that's right and your native language is
Afrikaans oh my god
but you speak English as if it were your
native language I've gone to English
schools my whole life yes all right
and you live in Singapore and you have
an interest in languages and in Asia
correct yes and you speak three Asian
languages learning a few more than that
but I guess I'm conversational or it can
help myself in about three or four you
okay so that's interesting and by the
way you have a YouTube channel where you
talk to your viewers about learning
languages and give them tips and so on
and I'm gonna have to subscribe so I can
improve my Korean which is No thank you
lagging behind but no it's interesting
so you speak three and you say you're
learning more and I always think it's
interesting the language does it
languages that people are learning be
good you know that's what that's what
we're struggling and that's what we're
trying to get a lot you know further
along and that's where we may say we
speak them and yet you know in our heart
of hearts that we don't speak to them as
well as we would like to speak hmm so
which are the ones that you are learning
I have been learning Korean for about 11
years 10 years and Japanese since 2013
and then dabbling on and off and
Mandarin Chinese Vietnamese Filipino
there are so many malay/indonesian yeah
but not that I can have a conversation
in those last ones though so you
basically your emphasises Asian
languages I would say so but recently
I've started becoming more interested in
Spanish and Hungarian so I just started
learning Spanish halfway through last
year and I've been babbling in Hungarian
for a while which I'd love to restart
this year mm-hmm so how do you juggle
all these languages the ones that you'd
like to go back and improve and the new
ones that you're exploring or trying to
get I'd love to ask you as well
I think I am not really one to make
language learning schedules I struggle
to stick to them and I feel really bad
if I don't follow a schedule rigorously
but that's something I'm trying to
implement for this year is to see if I
could just section off time for each
language every day or you know one
language per day in the week so so far
that's going well to schedule that time
but mostly the time I get the most
language learning in is when I'm just on
my phone online on Twitter on Instagram
watching something on Netflix will be in
a different language so I just make sure
to hear as much as I can in the other
languages but really sitting down and
studying from the book that is still
something I'm trying to work out for
myself
mm-hmm yeah no I we can discuss the the
difficulties of learning multiple
languages yeah I find that I mean I
would love to go but I've learned
languages that I couldn't speak now I
mean I could get them back pretty
quickly but I learned them for a
specific purpose like I was going to
Romania or I was going to Greece
Republic and then I did okay when I was
there but right now you said say
something in that language I can't yeah
you provided pretty quickly but I I feel
like that's like my French I can
understand it perfectly fine but I'm a
bit awkward to speak it's just not
coming out as fluidly interesting I was
talking to someone yesterday about um I
believe she's British the lady who
translated handguns vegetarian book into
English from Korean so she can read and
write Korean to such an extent that
she's able to translate these nuances in
the word but apparently she's not able
to speak it and that was very
interesting to me and I realized that's
actually how a lot of the Korean
education system is when teaching
English this are incredible at doing
exams learning vocabulary memorizing
rote but when you speak to them they
will struggle to produce English but do
they do they understand it well when
they hear it I don't know that's what
I'm wondering about really you must
pardon yeah yeah that's the part that
I'm not sure you can read but I'm
convinced that anyone who understands
well as if there's a conversation
there's
people all talking in different
directions and they understand
everything that's said I that person's
gonna be able to speak I just don't
believe that you can be you can have
good listening comprehension yeah for a
good vocabulary and that you are unable
to get the words out I don't I just
don't I had never met such a person mmm
you know I feel like you just read if
you can just read so then you're not
really worried about the sounds I mean
you need cons to speak if you have no
sounds that's be what you're if you are
able to hear the sounds clearly well
enough to understand and that you're not
able to speak
I think that's an unusual situation
mm-hmm could be wrong so you know I mean
speak with mistakes yeah yeah I mean my
focus is always on listening listening
is the easiest thing to do I don't spend
as much time on Netflix or on my iPhone
because you know if I'm actually gonna
work on my language where you know I'm
not doing something else then I will
read and I'll use link and I'll look at
words and plow through the language the
way I when I was doing I was gonna do
Persian Turkish and Arabic and so I said
you're not you're gonna create a hundred
links in each language so that way sure
that every day I was not neglecting one
of the three I've now decided I can't do
the three drop Turkish but I say you're
gonna at least do that and even that I
haven't been able to maintain the easy
thing to do is I go in there's a pond
new podcast in Arabic or Turkish I just
grab that listen to it in my car that's
so easy to do yeah sit down and try and
read that I'm paying people to
transcribe those so yeah and get in and
read them so I understand better yeah I
think sometimes people underestimate the
power of listening how much that
actually helps you back when I lived in
South Korea and still had a car I would
just pop in my textbook CD into the car
and listen to those phrases over and
over and once I went back to the actual
paper book and I was reading I actually
heard the same accent and voices of the
people who are who recorded the CD and
that just helped me so much more and
I personally I like our many stories is
sort of point of view stories hmm with
so much repetition yeah you're it the
same thing over and over and over again
you notice a little more each time and
that builds up then the momentum so that
then you're able to use those
so no listening is super powerful and
it's the easiest thing to do yeah but
Korean we were talking about Korean the
other day and and of course we both
agree that if you have a heaven
knowledge of Chinese characters that's
kind of the base of those East Asian
languages yes and so people who study
Korean without the Chinese characters
are at a disadvantage yes I would I
would say once you get to an
intermediate or advanced level knowing
the base of the Korean characters like
the sino-korean characters knowing where
they come from really helps you to infer
the meaning of new words not that you're
at a disadvantage if you can't read or
recognize a Chinese character right even
if it's written in tongue go knowing
which Chinese character will definitely
help you yeah I agree and that's you
know I always say Chinese tones are a
problem the characters are a problem but
building your vocabulary actually is
easier because you have all these little
components that repeat yes so you can
anticipate but this new or at least it's
easier to remember them because it has
components that you've seen in other
characters so if you can do that but
they're hidden in Korea mmm it's not
obvious even the view whatever it could
be various forms of art whereas in
Chinese or in Japanese if you see the
character you know what that you have a
good point
yeah so I always I wish there were some
map where you you're reading Korean on
the screen and you just toggle into
Hanyu hmm
that's a good idea to develop something
young so your channel you give people
advice on language learning in general
or specific advice on Asian ranges a bit
of both which sounds contradictory so I
did start out making general language
learning videos and now one of my videos
accidentally went viral in Korea
totally unplanned and I suddenly got an
influx of Korean viewers and viewers
interested in Korean well I decided I do
still want to keep making videos about
language learning so not just in Korean
but because there are so many people
interested in learning Korean I do focus
a lot on that and it is my most fluent
foreign language so I do have a lot
about Korean or Japanese lighting tips I
envy you your Korean I would love to be
fluent in Korean I envy your Chinese I
gotta put the effort in that's what you
know I saw the other day that poor
yellow had said that he was gonna give
up on Japanese I heard I saw that video
yeah there's no question he could murder
a police he's a very very good yeah
motivation isn't there the connection or
something and with me in Korean that's
kind of been missing I you know some bit
of content that really you know right
grabs me that kind of drives me so I
keep on being distracted how do you get
by other languages so how do you avoid
being distracted by new languages when
you're not as good as you'd like to be
in an old yeah that is such a problem
for me I'm such a dabbler and I get very
excited by shiny new things quickly I
guess for me I just really need to have
something that really grounds me
motivation to learn a language when I
started with Hungarian I was extremely
interested in Hungarian music and still
to this day when I listen to Hungarian
songs I really feel something like wow
the sangwich is so beautiful and that
alone is actually enough to keep me
going that with the Hungarian people
being extremely friendly and open to
people learning their language that's
something that keeps me going
mostly my motivation for learning a
foreign language is to understand
entertainment or music or literature
specifically because I'm a designer any
country that has a strong sense of
design or design education is really
helpful as well so what I'm trying to do
in Spanish right now is also part of
motivation so originally I was not
planning on learning Spanish at all
I think things happen in here we are I'm
learning Spanish but now after the three
months of you know excitement the
honeymoon period of learning line
I need something really to keep me
learning it I can't just do it with
music right so I'm trying to read one
user experience and user interface
design article in Spanish every week
it's pretty simple because a lot of it
is terms that I can recognize technology
or design terms but that's something
that I can really have ground me like if
I want to improve both my design skills
and Spanish this is something I can keep
going and it's hard to find something
like that in all your languages like I'm
still trying to find a ground or a base
of as to why I want to learn Burmese
other than I have to Burmese colleagues
there needs to be something more to that
and I'm sure I'll discover it once I get
into the language deeper of course and
if you're doing if you're doing say in
Spanish if you're using content that is
in an area that you're very familiar
with that's just that much easier yeah
yeah I don't mind the sort of dilettante
approach because whatever exposure I
have to like Romanian or Greek or urgent
or Arabic it's just interesting you're
learning stuff those people express
themselves and you learn a little bit
about the country so and it's lovely
that like you are an experienced
language learner and if you decide you
can learn Burmese you learn from me it's
like you're at this buffet table and you
can choose to have this or you can
choose to have that you could leave some
on your plate and go and grab something
else if you are that's actually a very
good metaphor but I do there is a lot of
criticism for those kinds of people
especially there's a video I uploaded
this year for my 12 language foci for
the year and the intention is not to say
I want to be fluent in 12 languages
the intention is I already speak some of
these languages they're at maintenance
mode some of these I just want to learn
how to read and write some of them I
just want to improve my speaking so it's
not 12 languages all out for one year
but people who just see that video in
that title they say that is such a
terrible technique you should just learn
one language to fluency but they don't
even know that I already do speak a few
to blue and see and I'm just adding on
but I just decided you know I'm doing it
for fun I'm not doing it for anyone else
if this is what I enjoy
is what enriches my life I'll just keep
doing it and and people tell you should
do this or you should do that language
learning is is for me and that's why I
think we shouldn't criticize others we
shouldn't criticize how well or poorly
we shouldn't criticize what they like to
do
it's like Moses McCormick who speaks an
amazing you know Moses Maher yes speaks
an amazing number of languages he's not
he's not you know brilliant in all of
them but he's made good yes quite a
variety of languages so why would people
criticize him why is that a bad thing to
do he has sampled to a you know a fair
degree of capability so many different
languages he has a sense of he has a bit
of a finger in I don't know Estonia
whatever it might be
he's a matter of the world in the true
sense so if that's then I had once an
exchange with this guy man in Japan and
he she spent two years on nothing but
Japanese paychecks
how can you fool japanese pitch accent
for two years it doesn't matter but but
that's him so that makes him happy all
the more power to him yeah yes and also
dictating what which languages other
people should learn I've had people who
are very passionate about their home
language which is wonderful to see but
the amount of comments I get in a day
about will you please learn XYZ language
or when are you I don't know I'm not
interested don't force me reasons you
should learn this language not anyway
very nice to talk to you and as I say
we'll put a link up to your channel so
people can now that they've met you they
can follow up especially if they're
learning Asian languages or just to get
a sense of your enthusiasm for learning
languages in general so thank you very
much thank you so much things we'll see
you at the next conference guys see you
thank you bye
okay hi Steve hi Lindy how are you thank
you great so good to have you here so we
had the we were able to meet each other
at polygon conference in Japan earlier
this year and I do believe there are
many people who know you and watch your
videos online but for those of my
viewers who don't would you please
introduce yourself okay well my name is
Steve Cochran I live in Vancouver Canada
I'm basically retired from the wood
business where I worked for over 40
years but I have a great interest in
languages languages that I learned I was
diplomat for seven years I studied in
France and in the last 10 12 years or
more I've become particularly interested
languages you know I'm 74 now I've
learned so some people say you can't you
can't learn languages past the age of
haters don't think that's not true with
my son we have created a website called
link LAN gqm which is kind of how I like
to learn and I have my youtube channel
lingo Steve great thank you I'll put all
those links below so Steve I'm going to
dive into the very pressing questions
that I have for you already
first one something that I receive a lot
is how do you manage to learn so many
languages at the same time the question
is more of how do you balance your time
do you schedule different languages for
different days how do you go about that
okay usually like I typically have not
learned languages at the same time I
tend to focus on one language at a time
that has always been my pattern so you
know I spend and you know it's become
faster but I would spend like two years
on Russian yeah maybe the first year I
didn't even speak just lots of listening
already check was like six months then I
had to go to Romania so I spent two
months on learning with Romania and then
my wife and I were heading off to Greece
so I spent actually six months on Greek
but then it's only recently that I said
so then I started Arabic and here
Vancouver there's not so many Arabic
speakers but there's lots of Iranians
learn the writing system
why don't I learn you know Farsi Persian
so that made it to and then my wife was
watching Turkish you know soap operas on
Netflix and I said that's kind of neat
I'll try learn Turkish so briefly I had
a period where I was trying to learn
three languages at the same time yeah
and my initial approach was go three
months three months three months and
then at the end of the three months I'd
fallen so far behind in the first one
that I said that's not good I'll try and
learn them together at the same time and
so what I did was I said I'm gonna make
sure that because it's difficult to
control like it's not I don't spend my
day language like there's lots of stuff
happening you know yeah stuff that I do
and so I said I'm gonna force myself to
create what we call links I gotta save a
hundred new words every day and each one
of the three languages and I was a
little able to maintain that for bottom
hmm maybe a month or so and then I
started not doing it like I was staying
up at eleven o'clock at night to make
sure I got 100 you know yeah I don't
want this obligation I want to do what I
like doing is I like listening stuff so
and then I said I'm gonna drop Turkish
because the the Persian and the the
Arabic reinforce each other because
they're both in the Arabic script so
every time I'm in there I'm improving my
ability to read and write know it takes
a long time to get good at reading in
another language like that's you may
learn the Cyrillic alphabet you may
learn Hangul and it's not that difficult
but to get good at it you have to read a
lot I do maybe you're able to do you
know to progress more quickly so I
decided that now so now I have no
particular routine I have certain
podcasts in Persian and Arabic I'll go
and grab the latest podcast listen to it
don't understand 20 30 % come home that
night and I'll try and read through it
on link and see if I can figure out what
they were talking about that's about it
no it's no system but then the question
would be how do you maintain the
languages that you started learning
years ago so maybe Russian or Romanian
how do you think well first of all
Russian is in that first dozen languages
I can turn my guy I have no problem with
Roxie what Romanian agreed there in that
other group which is I can't turn them
on and but because my my learning has
been based on a lot of listening
particularly men heavy to our mini story
so if I spend a few hours on many
stories in Greek
it'll I have no I have no fear that
it'll be gone you know remember when I
was listing at that
yeah let's come back so and and you know
obviously when I go to speak I'll
stumble but that's always the case at
first but when that can ramp up my
ability by doing a lot of listening and
reading and then I can go and start
talking to someone and really struggle
for the first 15 20 minutes and then it
just starts there so I never worry about
that I never worry about that there's no
way I don't think you can maintain that
you know instant you know deliverable
high-quality blah blah blah 20 languages
maybe that person exists I can't do it
me neither know something that I'm
realizing these days is how how fluid
these languages really are in terms of
how they fluctuate so I'm studying for a
Korean exam coming up and I'm focusing
all my efforts on Korean right now and
when I switch over to Japanese I find
that my current Japanese accent sounds
very Korean right and it's super
frustrating because I can hear myself
and I don't know how to fix it but then
you know a few months later or a few
months ago when I'm really focusing on
Japanese my Japanese accent is great and
then when I speak Korean Korean people
are like oh you sound like a Japanese
person speaking Korean you don't sound
like a American speaking Korean it's
weird and it's not really something that
I can control after so over many years
of learning these languages it's just
they're very fluid but that's true is
that everything better our native
language so if you were to go to Jeju
Island or something or if you were Osaka
you're Japanese if I go to Osaka I start
sounding more like someone from Osaka
yeah because in our in the languages
that we learn I think we are very easily
influenced by the yes absolutely
whereas our native language it kind of
stays yeah I even there we might be in
first
another question I get often is some
people feel that polygons are like some
kind of secret society and you have to
be able to speak a number of languages
to be able to call yourself a polygon
what do you think about the term
polyglot and the community and
exclusivity see I don't like the word
polyglot
hmm most English speakers don't know
what the word means it's true never I
know you prefer the term linguist
language because that is in fact the
English turn term it's not the vanished
term it's not the French term he's not
that Russian German but it is the
English term if you are up in a
dictionary most people don't know what
linguistics is yeah never heard of
linguistics they don't know what is that
such a thing exists I've never heard the
term polygon linguist means someone
who's good at languages good at
languages so even tomorrow I would much
prefer we call ourselves language lovers
so if I find the answer you're the same
way if you meet someone who speaks one
other language but speaks it very well
I'm full of admiration yes one one
language speaks Japanese only say French
in Japanese I'm full full of memories
and I think that's the way people are in
the polyglot community people are not
competing with each other they don't
down their nose and someone who only
speaks two languages absolutely yes
learning languages is fun projecting
yourself what I why I'm full of
admiration is cuz here's this person who
is let's say French and actually he's
behaving like a Japanese hmm well you
know that is very interesting to meet us
and you can do it in three languages so
much the better
so you're projecting yourself into this
other persona you're imitating your
cultures some extent that's fun and I
think that's what our group is all about
yeah and and it's not we're not
competing who has the most languages or
who speaks less absolutely that's right
happy to hear that coming from you I'm
sure that will give a lot of inspiration
to people and we should encourage more I
feel that we want to be a little careful
that we don't get too you know we're all
talking about learning
some language it's it's all about which
most people struggle to learn languages
yeah yeah we I still struggle with all
of them every day we all struggle but
you it you get but there are people to
go to Spanish fries for 10 years and
can't speak mm-hmm people who go through
school and can't speak when they
graduate you know do you think its
technique words mindset I think it's
well you know I think mindset is huge
mindset is huge
you have to so the person who goes to
and I know people like this you know
they go to their Spanish class at the
library they've been doing it for 10
years I think it's to some extent if
they don't listen enough my opinion yeah
they some level don't ever think you're
gonna become fluent whereas both you and
I it might be a struggle but if I can
learn that language if I put enough time
into it I will become fluent I won't
stop if I'm determined to get enough
vocabulary get there and I get to where
I can listen to things of interest to me
and all that I know and I know that if I
continue using the language and to me
using the language includes listening
reading I don't have to be speaking to
be using the brake is converting this
demeaning that's using the language and
if I do in cockpit I'll get there and
every time I'm doing it I'm getting
better so that's all positive if I sat
in a classroom and I had a teacher
explaining stuff to me and giving me
drills that I'm gonna get three of them
wrong and it's frustrating that I think
I wouldn't get anywhere either so yeah I
think that it's partly learning
technique it's partly obviously the
person who goes to the library all the
time doesn't have the self confidence or
doesn't have that initiative to take
charge of their own language yeah so and
time it takes time that's why again
listening is so great because you can do
it anytime anywhere
but it's make sense it's gotta be stuff
of interest it can't be you know
repetition is okay for a while but
repetition word we can tolerate the
repetition during the honeymoon period
as you yeah which
a great turn I like that once you pass
the honeymoon period you got to get
something interesting today and not be
repeating silly phrases absolutely then
lastly I have a lot of Japanese viewers
would you be comfortable and having a
little chat in Japanese
of course I'd even like to do it in
Korean just to show you how bad my
Koreans take a hamburger or oil
hey [ __ ] my [ __ ] audio oil yeah Oh
dr. disco yes sir you don't go mom
also on this unit yeah there you go
thank your step there kanji mass and
zinc are you insane baker's kinda like
it is so today much of a joke and maybe
in your statement
mine is epoch Sangeeta toxin keep this
tax on their their certain is indeed a
nice to know me
so go could uh could you uh no Coco [ __ ]
you go take a look at all they demote me
go go
thank you sir particular in this get ox
na say Steve your sunny cold war some
the news but she cannot much cachito
[Music]
University the negative on Iran the Kuna
Sunita
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
don't you mr. money
cuckoo hajima target is Russia and
Ukraine it is matter miss argot mistake
and the modernized
tronco who'd ever conquer the desert the
grants no joking you does she will come
on all cheer oh cool oh no Jesus also
mango because remind me to Oklahoma
being cursed undisclosed yo mama de
mucho me Sarkozy
how much do you like this new body
Bianca Yongsan Korea upcoming CD whoa
- boo boo toxins CD audio taxa sistema
de tama - woman's your Vancouver dr.
suno kutah 9 this job did you go to Jean
Monnet die what I do they all died
put me down what I'm doctor what Jean
Piaget's passing me Chiang Khong yeah
you might need a Madoka
yeah and you're not warm when she's icy
young guys hear that
doctor what Oh what is it go don't go no
wha good news you should wash your [ __ ]
yeah
watch it boy die sanborns
yeah mmm
yeah don't know yet right but no you
have to get together with eventually at
some point as you know this will get my
fingers it's it's input I believe an
input but at some point come speak a lot
you have yeah lot if you want to speak
well you have to speak a lot and I don't
believe it matters when you start people
wish you're surrounded by the language
as I was in Japan I started speaking
very early it was Russia and I had no
one to speak to I don't speak early but
whenever at some point you don't speak
mm-hmm and when and that's why I think
if you have a lot of vocabulary and good
comprehension you can get into some
meaty
conversations that Janee so to be
struggling and spent an hour on I
talking with someone and you got a
vocabulary of 200 words you'd be better
off spending that time trying to
increase your familiarity with the
language either otherwise you're just
chasing these too many words but that
being said for people who are shy or
have low self confidence just being able
to use those 200 words in a bit of
conversation does help boost you and
motivate you first I'm sure it does but
I I find that when I have started early
like in Korean I started early because I
thought Korean will be easy Japanese
really and I would sit there and I'm
sweating because it's so hard I don't
understand what she's saying and I
really put the words together and I find
that is an answer no I don't mind
actually speaking Korean I don't speak
but I can I have a limited vocabulary
understand what people are saying so I'm
comfortable speaking and so if I tried
to have more opportunity to speak then I
could improve like I have lots of I have
had lots of opportunity in Japanese and
Chinese just be according to link
statistics I have 40,000 words in Korea
crazy Wow
so I've done a lot of reading list in
Korean but I never used so really I
should start using record yeah well
Steve thank you so much for sharing your
insights and tips it's great to talk to
you great to see you at the next Pollak
conference are you in a Mexico
I hope so if I can afford a ticket it's
very far from Singapore okay thank you
thank you bye
[Music]
you
[Music]